Good evening everybody.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been happy.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhodasa
homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one so we were making our way through dependence origination and uh i just uh question came through let's have a look if i can find it
um say a bit more about basic delusion unknowing part is this something we accept as a condition of life does it fall away with enlightenment does consciousness dissolve and become intuitive awareness a higher form of knowing any right well i'm hoping that that question will uh will be answered as we go along and if it's not uh the questioner will surely send me another email um
Just for that part about the unknowing or the not knowing, of course there is something that doesn't know, there's something that is not seeing properly, right?
One of the key phrases of the Buddha is to understand and see how things come to be, or how things have come to be, because he's basically into process.
So there is something there which is knowing, right?
The knowing.
And of course, that's what we come to understand to be our awareness.
But we'll come to that.
So just to recap very quickly, we have this baseline.
at the bottom of it there is this misunderstanding this this um delusion so remember a delusion is that a person has a wrong view of something and presumes it's correct they oh the whole uh definition of delusion is that the deluded don't know they are deluded as soon as you know you're deluded then in a sense you're you're you're going to find your way out of that delusion
So from ignorance we have this delusive way of behaving in the world and that manifests as our habits, right?
And every time one of these habits comes up, it comes into consciousness.
The consciousness is the screen upon which it arises.
So the Buddha talks about the Sankara and the consciousness as two sheaths of hay.
Remember, they're all agricultural metaphors.
So to stack the hay, having cut it into sheaths, they would stack it one against the other.
I'm sure you've seen that.
um in pictures european pictures even so and then uh depending on that on consciousness on that screen the body heart and mind arise and with it of course your sixth sense bases remember the sixth is is the is the mind and uh and then once that's settled every moment you've got that underneath every moment uh that is contact okay
So we're moving on from contact.
At contact, there are the six sense bases, the sense objects that they are contacting, and of course consciousness.
If any of those three are not there, then contact is not possible.
so obviously if you are if you're deaf uh you won't be able to hear sounds if you're in an in quietly a very quiet room uh there won't be anything to hear as such and if you're not awake if you're not conscious then you won't hear it anyway so those three factors have to be there to make contact now the next stage is evading a feeling
and feeling is uh at the simplest level we've done this actually at some point uh just the five feelings there's physical feelings sensations um which are pleasant or unpleasant and there are mental uh feelings uh emotions moves as we experience them in the body as as feelings
pleasant and unpleasant.
And there's a whole area in between pleasant and unpleasant, which I normally talk of as just neutral.
The word that's used is upeka, which really has many meanings, but it just means neutral and neutral feeling.
It's neither pleasant or unpleasant.
If we get right close to it, actually, you'll see that it shades.
It shades one way or the other.
Now, that's the point where we either like or dislike, right?
That's how you can say you experience it.
I like it or I don't like it.
Okay?
But then, remember, it's the next point, the tanha, where there's this desire for something, either a desire to get it or a desire to get rid of it.
And when it's unskillful like that, what we're doing is we're trying to manipulate the world in order to create this inner sense of happiness.
So that's your tanha.
Even desires arising out of compassion, truthful joy, caring and all that, will unfortunately have some level of self involved.
And that's why you have to be, shall we say, super aware when you want to do something out of the goodness of your heart.
You've got to actually say to yourself, well, I'm doing this for my benefit because sometimes you have to do something for yourself.
I am doing it entirely for the benefit of others or both.
Now, in the monastic life, and indeed when I was in Sri Lanka especially, you don't say thank you.
See, if you give me, if you're, say, in the East and you offer me food, I don't say thank you.
If you give me a present, an alarm clock, a mobile, I don't say thank you.
I receive it.
you see now if the giver thinks oh they didn't say thank you you know how horrible you know how uncivilized you see then a part of their giving was to get the praise see so it's a mirror back to the giver so if you give something and the person doesn't say thank you then and you have a reaction to that then there's a part of you that was giving it a little pat on the back now in our culture of course you have to say thank you and else you get very upset
There was a lovely occasion at the Buddhist Vihara where Vajra Bailey, who was actually my first teacher, we put her ashes in the pond here.
It was a lovely little ceremony.
She was in the room with Bhante in the Vihara, and somebody came and gave him a book, you see, and she was trying to teach him sort of British ways, or at least Western ways, but British ways.
so when he took the book of course he didn't say anything he just put it down to the side so he he said to her she said to him uh vanity when somebody gives you something you have to say thank you and he said why it's my book he's only giving his book back you don't understand why he should say thank you so uh this business of thank you is uh is is a moot point uh so
uh generally speaking though if we if you know or if we're coming from the good heart then we can presume that there's there's not that much greed involved you know but when uh when the tanha is there there is definitely some strong desire so that's the position of um of now of tan have you invaded like it want it like it want it okay there's your two distinct um two distinct
reactions or two distinct responses to an original impact an original contact okay so you know very simply uh on a hot day like this has been very hot you see you might um you might see an ice cream uh or you might have ice cream in the fridge and the thought comes up you see so that was your first contact and then with it they'll become oh yeah i'd like to like and then and then the wanting
okay now the next stage we'll come back to that in a minute the next stage is this uh grasping it's translated as grasping upadana um this is uh came across that image of fire and how in you know in in our more modern science it's the friction between two sticks that are creating the heat that creates the fire whereas in uh
In their physics, the rubbing of two sticks was creating conditions for the fire element, which is all around, to come down to the wood and grasp it.
So it was that idea of grasping something.
Now, the grasping has four different qualities.
It can be a grasping because of just sensual desire that has in it.
It's also a grasping coming from views, you know, this is mine, I want this, right?
Right, we'll come to a minute.
There's also doing things for rituals that you think are actually material to the path.
So in Buddhist terms, you know, making offerings to the Buddha, lighting candles,
Even the offering of help or presence to the needs or requisites to the monks is all you need to do to become liberated.
Well, that would be a wrong understanding.
now the actual rituals themselves may be fine you know lighting candles lighting incense all creates a good atmosphere in order to sit uh but if if you if if a person think that that is somehow crucial to the path then in a sense they they've misunderstood but the core upadana the core grasping is identity personality view this is me i
so there you have it there you have that flow so you've got the contact you've got the want so you've got the contact you've got the like you've got the want and then you've got the i want now uh it's only at the i want actually that you're suffering you're not suffering when the desire is there
um it's that it's that little moment i mean these things happen so quickly in ordinary daily life that it's you know it's almost well it's difficult to separate it frankly i would say generally impossible uh unless you're really you know with it unless you're really awake uh wide awake but in meditation you can see it
just very simple.
You might get an itch on your nose and it's not likable.
You want to scratch it and then I will scratch it.
Before you know it, your hands move to give it a little scratch.
So that moment of identity is the moment when you're actually moving with
that desire and that's when that's when the suffering comes when you identify with the reaction so um even though being in a state of desire is uncomfortable right so you can you can feel the desire to scratch your nose you see and it's there you can ask yourself well when i take a really objective position to the itching and to the feeling of wanting to scratch
is there any suffering as such okay it's the same with with pain in the knee from the sitting posture you might say to yourself oh you know payment i'm going to change posture but if you hold it there for a minute then you'll see there's the desire to move and if you're objective about it if you can actually lift the aware lift the awareness out of that connection and see it objectively there's no suffering
But there's always that little sort of in-between bit where you're sort of falling into the identity, but not completely.
And that can be a very uncomfortable position until you give in and then move your leg.
um so uh now at that point you see uh there's there's there's only the identity so we need one more factor to to complete the act and that of course is the will which takes the potential of wanting into an action and that's the bother that's the becoming so it is a comma it's an act
It's a bhava, it's a becoming because the self is involved.
There's a creation of a self, right?
And of course, there's that power that makes it happen, the will.
So those are your three components.
Although the Buddha does state that action and the will are one and the same thing, okay?
So that's your process
within dependent origination, right?
There is a bit ending, but that's your main process.
The contact, the liking or disliking, the wanting or not wanting, the I want,
I don't want, and then the getting, okay?
The achieving or the actual process of the action.
Then of course, you've got the beginning of that process, the middle bit, the growing old, the decay, and then the ending of it.
So that's the last bit.
Now that's if you look at this dependence origination from a moment to moment process, which is perfectly viable.
but it's also seen as a three life process so that in the past life you've developed all these conditionings you're born and then you go through this whole process that we've just discussed and then when you die uh sorry and then in life you you're born you grow old and you die so the whole process is one of of circularity okay
So there are two interpretations.
But for our purposes as seekers of liberation from suffering, it would be more skillful to see it as a moment-to-moment process.
So it's not always happening.
It's not happening when you're asleep, for instance.
So that's the dependent origination.
I'm actually going to put as a note underneath the video the two books that are very viable.
There's one written by a Thai scholar called Venerable Paiyuto.
Where is it?
Here we are.
And you can download it as a PDF.
It's just called Causation.
Yes, Causation.
Oh, dear me.
The great discourse on... No, no, no, no, no.
Dependent origination, the Buddhist law of conditionality.
That's it.
So don't worry, I'll put it on the info that goes with the video.
But having read that and feeling that you want to go a bit deeper, there's a book by Vikku Bodhi on the great discourse of causation.
And that really takes you into a different level of understanding.
But in terms of our liberation from suffering, the core understanding is that
If you, if we hang on to see that desire of wanting, not wanting what is likable or unlikable and have that moment of awareness where we can say, well, look, it's, it would be skillful for me to do this.
It would be unskillful for me to do this.
And if it's unskillful, you just wait for that energy to exhaust itself.
And if it is skillful, of course you do it.
That in itself is a purification of the heart.
And B, you're beginning to understand the cause of suffering, which is that form of desire, and that itself is an entrance into one of the paths and fruits.
So remember, there are four stages, the stream entrance, the once returner, the non-returner, and finally the arahat, the arahat himself, the completely liberated.
So that little bit there between vedana, feeling, liking, disliking, and tanha, wanting, not wanting, that's your escape.
That's our escape.
I'm still working on it.
Okay.
I think we'll just very quickly finish off with the fact that there is, of course, a reverse to that.
so it goes it reads like this with the remainderless fading away and cessation of ignorance the remainderless fading away and cessation of ignorance comes the cessation of habits volitional formations and so forth with the cessation of formations comes the cessation of consciousness now be careful here this is the consciousness of the candor
with the cessation because the buddha is conscious i mean he's walking around and he's eating and he's chatting so he's not and he's fully liberated right it's the consciousness of delusion the delusive consciousness that arises uh yes remember the english word is so confusing because consciousness is um also means a sort of knowing it doesn't just mean a representation on a screen
With the sensation of consciousness is the sensation of mentality, materiality, body and mind.
With the cessation of materiality and mentality, the cessation of the sixfold sense base.
With the cessation of the sixfold sense base, cessation of contact.
Remember, this is wrong contact, deluded contact.
with the cessation of contact cessation of feeling with the cessation of feeling the cessation of craving with the cessation of craving the cessation of clinging cessation of clinging cessation of becoming with the cessation of becoming cessation of birth with the cessation of birth aging and death sorrow lamentation pain grief and despair all cease such is the cessation of this whole mass of suffering
In this way, Ananda, a bhikkhu can be called skilled independent origination.
So that's really core teaching.
The Dependent Regeneration is really core teaching.
And it's worth reading that book I mentioned and just see if you get a little bit deeper into it.
And then to use your meditation to actually see those steps very clearly, the contact, but especially this Vedana, the feeling, pleasant, unpleasant, the wanting, to really feel that.
You know, what is a desire?
What does a desire feel like?
So remember, desire always comes from a place of unsatisfactoriness and is itself unsatisfactory until it's fed.
And there are some desires that we should feed and there are some that we shouldn't.
So I think that, yes, so we're moving on, time moves on.
So I think that brings us to the end of that little bit.
this is actually a discourse the buddha thought highly of so we'll we'll go into it so we're going to the other parts um tomorrow very good i can only hope my words have been of some assistance and that i've not caused even greater confusion and that by your practice you will be liberated from all sufferings sooner rather than later